en baladant sur facebook je suis tombé
sur cette vidéo qu'est ce qui s'est
passé est ce que ce sont vraiment les
ondes 5 g qui ont fait sobre et si oui
par quel mécanisme la sent chez c'est le
successeur de la cache la nouvelle
technologie en train d'être déployé dans
toute la france avec sa l'internet sur
ton téléphone pourrait être 20 fois plus
rapide une vidéo youtube kaka chargé en
moins d'un quart de seconde
sauf que pour beaucoup cette invention
serait dangereuse tumeur dégâts ou
cerveau destruction de la nature comme
t'il vraiment qu'ils du gouvernement des
opérateurs mobiles ou des mouvements
citoyens se trouvent les ondes sont
elles un danger pour comprendre les
polémiques
on va revenir à la base qu'est ce qu'une
onde électromagnétique ce mot fait peur
mais est ce que tu savais que même au
fin fond de la campagne
tu es constamment baigner dans des
angles car tout ce que tu vois la
lumière les couleurs ce sont des ondes
électromagnétiques des sons qui se situe
au centre de ce grand spectre
électromagnétique tout à gauche vous
avez les infrarouges
à droite les ultraviolets ça ce sont les
rayonnements que vous ne voyez pas sauf
si par exemple tu as un casque
infrarouge militaire ça permet de voir
cette lumière invisible
cette chaleur est en fait une lumière
qui émane actuellement de ton corps si
on voit plus loin dans le spectre sur le
rayonnement infrarouge pour trouver des
trucs rigolos comme les ondes de ton
micro ondes ou le wifi oui oui un tory
fils un peu comme de la lumière tombe
ici et met des photos son ordinateur les
voix mais pas toi la différence entre
ces différents types d'onde ça va être
leur longueur d'onde la lumière visible
à une longueur d'onde
à l'échelle d'une bactérie une radio
c'est de l'ordre du mètre voire du
kilomètre ça veut dire qu'une longueur
d'onde peut littéralement faire ta
taille voire beaucoup plus là où ça
devient dangereux
c'est quand les ont tous deux triptyques
longueur d'onde pour ça faut remonter
dans le spectre et s'intéresser aux
ultraviolets rayons x et o
là c'est pour ça qu'on te dit que de
mettre de la crème solaire c'est pour ça
que quand tu passes une radio le médecin
se protège la réalité c'est que dans ces
conditions tu te fait bombarder parmi
nous et au monde
l'anneau métriques des ondes dites
ionisants elles sont tellement
énergétique qu elles peuvent perturber
les flics trop venté atom ça à produire
des effets en chaîne qui amène à la
destruction des cellules et
potentiellement des cancers ok
maintenant que je vous ai fait peur où
se trouvent les extrêmes j'ai là dedans
alors non je vous rassure elles ne sont
pas ionisantes associer la 5g à des
radiations nucléaires
c'est très malhonnête au contraire la 5g
à des longueurs d'onde plutôt grande
jusqu'à 1 cm pour info un les ondes wifi
c'est autour de 10 cm ouais mais vous
allez me dire ton histoire de taille là
ça compte pas trop un four à micro-ondes
c'est aussi des grosses longueurs d'onde
et pourtant tu y mets la main ça crabes
oui et cet exemple est plutôt
intéressant car sache-le maison de ton
ici et les ondes qui chauffe des
aliments sont de la même longueur d'onde
alors pourquoi mon wifi ne fait pas
chaud fait monter parce que il y a deux
autres paramètres le focus et la
puissance un micro-ondes concentre
londres dans un petit volume
là où le wifi envoie ses ondes un peu
partout un micro-ondes opera mille oif
plat ou le wifi est à 0,1 watt dix mille
fois moins de quoi et c'est ça qui pose
problème avec la 5g blonde est certes
inoffensive mais là où la 4g envoie des
ondes un peu partout comme ton wifi l'un
5g vallée concentrés dans des espaces de
tirs très précis à très haute puissance
c'est ce qu'on appelle un réseau phase
et ça ça fait flipper mais c'est des
tirs de quelques watts à peine plus que
la 4g vous n'allez pas cuire sur place
faudrait attire 100 fois plus puissant
pour que cela commence à peine à vous
qui cote est en réalité la 5g permettra
paradoxalement d'émettre moins donc au
lieu d'arroser tout à fait une puissance
les ondes sont répartis beaucoup plus
intelligemment tout aussi paradoxalement
si certains vivaient dans la peur d'être
entouré d'onde la 5g passera à peine les
murs de votre maison
ce sont des ondes d'assez courte portée
elle vous pénètreront beaucoup moins
facilement que la wii fit ou la 4g si la
5g avait existé avant lui aussi ses
avantages aurait sûrement été utilisé
pour prouver que la 5g c'est le bien et
le wifi le mal on ne prend que ce qui
nous arrange
mais alors pourquoi les arbres sont
cramés on va revenir sur cette vidéo
facebook avec l'arbre les habitants de
cette ville britannique très inquiet au
naturellement demandé à la
désinstallation de l'antenne la mairie
refuse et gagne son procès les ondes
sont mises hors de cause car il ya plein
d'autres raisons qui peuvent expliquer
ce qui s'est passé avec l'arbre le fais
déjà que ça peut être naturel c'est
assez commun de voir ça sur les arbres
possibilité que la personne est appliqué
des produits chimiques elle même
le doute est permis puisque de toute
évidence le sol de l'arbre est traitée
chimiquement car oui la cause peut être
humaine c'est un peu comme ces
expériences qui montrent que les graines
germées plus en présence de wifi oppose
à côté des graines un portable bien
brûlant avec un ventilo qui a 16 bien
l'air et au duc seul le wifi qui en est
la cause oui bah là non les causes c'est
la chaleur et le ventilo on a fait de
vrais tests scientifiques avec les
plantes et ni la wi fi et nilin 5g nous
montrer d'effet négatif notable et
répétable pourtant des photos comme ça
il y en a plein et à chaque fois ça peut
s'expliquer par exemple ici c'est un
effet de perspective ya l'arbre et il ya
l'antenne derrière car oui on essaye de
faire des antennes qui ressemblent à des
arbres pour mieux s'intégrer au paysage
bon ok ça c'est un vrai argument contre
la 5g c'est moche mais s'il n'y a pas
d'effet sur les plantes peut-il y en
avoir sur les animaux il y avait cette
histoire de mort de centaines d'oiseaux
pays-bas en 2018 mais là encore c'était
de la désinformation
l'article était complètement piper la
cause était tout autre
mais oui de forton peuvent légèrement
désorienter les oiseaux et les abeilles
leur sens étant basé sur un compas
magnétique naturel mais non ça ne les
tue pas en même temps le mec des oiseaux
avait lancé la rumeur qui a affirmé que
les incendies en californie était une
punition de lely pour imposer la 5g avec
internet c'est très facile de prendre
quelque chose d'anecdotique et de se
tromper sur les causes et les effets si
demain tu meurs en mangeant de la
ratatouille suffirait de prendre une
photo de toi avec ton plat et les
réseaux ferrés la suite
le pire c'est au royaume-uni aux
états-unis actuellement il y a une
théorie du complot qui voudrait que la
5g soient liés à la pandémie actuelle
genre la 5g renforce le virus ou qu'il a
été diffusée volontairement par le
gouvernement profitant ainsi du
confinement pour installer les antennes
ah non mais quand les journaux sont
obligés de tirer ça tu te dis quand même
que la psychose va beaucoup
trop loin le ms a pu conclure sur la 5g
ils disent les connaissances
scientifiques sont désormais plus
complète que celle que l'on possédait
sur la plupart des produits chimiques
ceci dit certains n'y crois toujours pas
l'om est serait dans le complot dont le
complot sauf que quand ça les arrange
parce que effectivement l'om s class la
5g comme possiblement cancérigènes et
c'est un argument souvent utilisé sauf
que c'est cancérigène dans la même
catégorie que l'aloe vera ou les légumes
en saumure
en fait cette catégorie regroupe tous
les agents on ne peut pas être sûr à
100%
et puisqu'on ne peut pas être sûr de
grand chose bref faites attention aux
études foireuse que vous voyez parfois
passer c'est un peu comme ces soi-disant
des études américaines qui prouve que la
bière en intelligente et que le sexe
vous fait dire plus vite c'est n'importe
quoi et c'est généralement très vite des
bunkers doux que la peur des ondes est
un gros business juteux
ça permet de vendre des brouilleurs
d'ondés et d'autres objets pour vous en
protéger
mais face à ses doutes pourquoi nous
imposer la 5g et ça c'est une vraie
question pourquoi il n'ya pas de
démocratie quand il s'agit d'une
nouvelle technologie à nous sont imposés
sans qu'on ait notre mot à dire
et fatalement les citoyens qui essaye de
se défendre face à sa part consulte une
information alternative souvent d'assez
mauvaise qualité et surtout mensongère
sauf que la question de la 5g
c'est la même qui s'est posée au moment
de l'arrivée du téléphone portable et de
la wi fi
à l'époque certains étaient terrifiés à
l'idée d'avoir une box ces jeux il la
mettait dans une pièce à part ou
éteignez la boxe avant de dormir
certains scientifiques parlent et de la
wi fi comme d'une catastrophe sanitaire
majeure une école en floride a failli
même retiré ses installations sous la
pression du public
ma question est donc si vos parents
avaient voté contre la wifi début des
années 2000 auriez vous trouvez ça
normal d'en être privée aujourd'hui la
5g n'est pas une évidence
actuellement mon internet marche bien
sur mon téléphone j'ai pas vraiment
besoin de plus sauf que la cat y est à
bout de souffle avec l'arrivée des
objets connectés des voitures autonomes
ou du streaming en haute qualité
nous fallait une nouvelle technologie si
vous avez déjà été un concert avec des
milliers de téléphone allumé mais bien
que c'est impossible de capter quoi que
ce soit imaginez ça dans dix ans partout
tout le temps
la 5g c'est aussi la possibilité de ne
pas avoir de latence de pouvoir
pratiquer la chirurgie à distance
instantanément sans avoir dix secondes
de décalage comme quand tu regardes ton
streaming favoris et enfin l'un ça que
j'ai c'est plus écologique
alors je sais que l'argument a l'air
foireux comme ça la 5g va demander plus
d'antennes puisque les ondes sont de
courtes distances plus antenne c'est
donc plus d'exploitation de ressources
naturelles mais en même temps la 5g un
réseau plus intelligent plus ciblées y
aura potentiellement moins de gâchis
énergétique
alors maintenant soyons honnêtes si
j'avais une antenne 5g à ma fenêtre
bon même si je sais que c'est pas très
dangereux je serai pas non plus très
content et pas très rassurée je sais
aussi très bien que la 5g actuellement
c'est une histoire de guerre commerciale
et de gros sous avec des vrais enjeux de
sécurité nationale veut que on fait tout
en chine et qui a la peur de
l'espionnage
tout ça ce sont des arguments dans le
débat et on doit pouvoir en discuter
la seule chose que je demande c'est
qu'on soit honnête
le jour où on aura le petit cinq géants
ou de son portable on sait que ce sera
difficile de revenir en arrière comme
c'est difficile de repasser en 3g ou en
edge le monde change vite et c'est comme
cette histoire de masques si on
n'anticipe pas maintenant si on fait pas
les choses rapidement avant que la vague
arrive on va être beaucoup à râler on
commence à peine cette chaîne youtube
avec la team est la même à tarte
donc si vous voulez nous soutenir à voir
plus de vidéos penser s'il vous plaît à
vous abonner said you tu vas nous
remonter dans l'algorithme ça permet à
ce genre de vidéos d'être vu par le plus
de monde possible ça nous motive aussi à
continuer merci de m'avoir suivi merci à
tous les monteurs et la team de
rédacteur allez les amis